be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about static and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
not only will you stop asking me to make
this video in the comments but you'll
also have it you'll also have a strong
understanding of his character and why
it was that he was made so in 1993 in
order to rectify an under-representation
of minorities in mainstream comic books
a group of african-american comic
creators including Dwayne McDuffie
Dennis Cowen Michael Davis and Derrick
Dingle founded milestone media a company
that would go on to launch a lot of
comics that featured african-american
protagonists as a result the first line
of of books published by milestone was
static which featured a teenager named
Virgil Ovid Hawkins a name that was
inspired by an african-american student
that was denied admission to a law
school at the University of Florida in
1949 now as far as the inspiration
behind static and an interview with
world's finest online largely considered
to be one of the best sources of
animated DC news one statics co-creators
Dwayne McDuffie stated the static had
been based heavily on the teenage
version of Marvel spider-man and was
originally developed for a project that
McDuffie had been working on for Marvel
Comics
that for various reasons never came to
fruition in addition to this McDuffie
also explained that he felt there was an
unfulfilled need for a teenage character
that audiences could relate to
since spider-man was now being written
as an adult and he felt the static could
actually fill that void now having said
that the static made his debut in issue
number one of his self-titled series in
June of 1993 and which were introduced
to virtual Hawkins a high school student
that much like Peter Parker is somewhat
of a nerd much like Peter Virgil was
depicted as having an affinity for
science but also has other interests
including Collie books role-playing
games and science fiction to this end
Virgil often found himself the victim of
bullying especially at the hands of a
gang member named Francis stone
following a particularly violent
encounter with Francis Virgil
accompanies a friend to Parris Island
one of the roughest parts of Dakota
where his friend gives him a gun in
order to exact revenge on Francis
while Virgil does find himself unable to
use the gun he also finds himself in the
middle of a gang war and so during an
attempt to suppress the brawl police
unleash tear gas that combined a
chemical designed to allow long
the truck any perpetrator that escaped
before being apprehended however things
go awry when the tear gas proved lethal
to almost everyone who was exposed due
to a compound called Quantum juice that
have been added to the tear gas
unbeknownst to the police as a result
the 10% that did survive were
transformed either into monsters or into
super humans an event which was used by
milestone media to jumpstart their
super-powered community now following
this virtual found himself possessing
the ability to manipulate
electromagnetism shortly after
discovering these abilities virgil
decides to use them to become a
superhero and adopts the moniker a
static throughout a solo series static
would further mirror the character
development seen in the early issues of
spider-man as he struggle to maintain
the balance between the responsibilities
of his powers and the good of society
with the pressure of trying to be an
ordinary teenager in addition to this
the series would see static engage in
typical superhero adventures which saw
him battling supervillains which were
also created by the quantum juice
incident including Francis stone who had
been given pyrokinetic powers and
adopted the supervillain identity of hot
streak now in addition to the superhero
adventures static series also dealt with
real-life struggles that every teenager
must see including complicated romantic
relationships with multiple girlfriends
as well as bullying as his friend Rick
stone is subjected to torment by his
fellow students after coming out as a
homosexual now a milestone colleagues
would initially enjoy significant
success through their african-american
centered lineup unlike many independent
publishers at the time they also had the
publishing power and advanced printing
process of DC Comics behind them as well
as a stable of popular and respected
writers and artists as the driving
creative force behind their books in the
early years of the company it seemed as
if milestone founders prediction there
was a gap in the market for minority
characters or proven to be correct
however shortly after the launch of
milestone comics the coming book
industry as a whole has suffered a crash
during the 1990s and what we call the
comic bust this couple with the fact
that milestones titles were not really
accessible to anyone other than
customers of the color book specialty
stores as well as higher cover prices
than competing books proved to be
obstacles that the young company was
unable to overcome as a result milestone
media saw their comic book sales
continuing to slump throughout the
to 90s and made the decision to cease
all publications of their books in 1997
which saw a static run come to an end
with issue number 45 the so in the year
2000 static was given his own animated
series huddle static shock on one of
others the culmination of an effort
they've been in the works since the
launch of milestone comics the 1993 to
develop an animated series based on
milestone characters to this end the
show debuted to tremendous success and
was renewed for a second season nearly a
month after premiering at the same time
the series Otis success to several
factors including the fact that it was
fully integrated as part of the popular
DC Animated universe and included
appearances from heroes such as Batman
and Robin Superman and Green Lantern
while the show was targeted toward a
younger audience in the static comic
book its willingness to tackle heavier
issues such as gang violence drugs
homelessness and racism made it popular
among multitudes of fans from virtually
all ages as a result the origin of
static in the animated series was
largely the same as a comic although
there were some changes such as the fact
that Virgil's mother a regular character
in the comics had died in the cartoon a
choice made by writers in order to focus
on the relationship between Virgil and
his father in addition to this first row
would also make appearances at other DC
animated shows including Justice League
Unlimited and Young Justice and so due
to the popularity of the animated series
DC Comics published a miniseries
entitled static shock rebirth of the
cool by the original creative team of
Dwayne McDuffie and jon paulien in 2001
marking static shocks returned to comics
after a four-year absence
although the animated series and a new
miniseries would mark the height of
statics popularity the character soon
experienced another lengthy hiatus as
static shock was cancelled in 2004 after
four seasons despite continuing to
garner decent ratings with low
merchandise sales being cited as the
reason for cancellation that said 2008
saw New Life for static as well as
several other milestone characters as DC
Comics executive editor Dan DiDio
announced that the milestone universe
and characters would be returning but
this time is part of the mainline DC
Universe looking to find a way to
achieve this is part of Grant Morrison's
final crisis event the space-time
continuum was threatened by Darkseid in
the aftermath of this both a DC Universe
and the milestone universe were met with
extinction
however Dharma a character originally
appearing in
while stone series hardware with the
ability to work reality is able to merge
the two universes into one this act
effectively absorbs the milestone
characters into the DC Universe proper
as well as give them an entirely new
continuity and a miniseries titled
terror Titans written by Sean McKeever
the static is kidnapped by the terrorize
and forced to fight in the darkside club
under the influence of the anti-life
equation after being freed static joins
the Teen Titans at the invitation of
Wonder Girl in Teen Titans number 69
also under the writing of McKeever
during his time with the Teen Titans
static helps defeat Jericho a former
member of the group and son of
Deathstroke that had taken over cyborgs
body and used it in an attempt to kill
the new and original Teen Titans during
this time static is able to overload
cyborgs body with a strong electrical
charge effectively saving the entire
team following this in Teen Titans
number 79 now under the writing of
Felicia Henderson static returns to his
hometown of Dakota after he finds out
that it's Simpsons including his sister
Sharon had been infected with a deadly
disease upon his return he attacks a lab
that's created the virus but is ambushed
by Holocaust a milestone villain the
super strength durability stamina and
agility as well as the power of
pyrokinesis where static is in prison at
the lab alongside aqua girl
Wonder Girl and bombshell before
escaping and joining the rest of the
team Titans to defeat Holocaust and Teen
Titans number 87 Felicia Henderson's
final issue on the series saw static
accompanying the rest of the team to
rescue Raven from another dimension
where she's being held prisoner by wild
a villain that was created out of Ravens
lifeforce while she was travelling
across dimensions searching for her
father Trigon where static is able to
locate Raven and the team is able to
rescue her static also discovers
something about wilds dimension that's
shipped him of his powers that were
Sadler convinces Virgil to go to Cadmus
labs in hopes of finding a way to get
his powers back
following Felicia Henderson's departure
from the title the Teen Titans was taken
over by writer JT Crowell and did not
feature static that said in 2011 DC
Comics in an effort to bolster sales
initiated a line wide relaunch of their
entire universe meaning the Teen Titans
along with all of the
other titles were cancelled following
the flashpoint event a new universe was
created as DC we launched 52 new series
under the banner of the new 52 which saw
almost all of the continuity that
existed prior to this point wiped out to
this end DC gave static his second
ongoing series as part of the launch of
the new 52 in November 2011 with static
shock number one written by Scott
McDaniel and John Watson during this
series Virgil is fully in control of his
powers and working for STAR Labs in New
York City after his family relocated
from Dakota in addition to this the
series features several new enemies such
as piranha sunspot and viral as well as
updated versions of classic milestone
villains such as hot streak and dr.
animo
however despite static spash popularity
static shock was one of the lowest
selling new 52 titles and was canceled
during the first wave of cancellations
following the relaunch lasting only
eight issues and so following this
cancellation static makes an appearance
in Teen Titans number six and it's
implied that he's a member of the team
but does not make any further
appearances in the book that said as far
as the DC Universe as it exists
following rebirth we have yet to see
static appear and it's unclear whether
or not DC actually has any plans for the
character and the immediate future but
with that being said we're going to
bring this to an end and I'm really
hoping that with this video you kind of
realize why I didn't really do anything
before because there's really not much
to this guy's character he's made like a
handful of appearances but people only
really like it because of the animated
series so yeah anyway we're going to
wrap this video up and I will catch you
all later peace